>> CAN YOU SUPPORT COPS AND
TROOPERS?
NOT ACCORDING TO THESE PARTY IS.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THAT IS
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY, THEY POSTE
PICS AND VIDEOS OF HER MOM'S
60TH BIRTHDAY BASH ON HER
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT.
MUCH LIKE MY HOT TUB PETTING ZOO
.
IT WAS A COWBOY THEMED AFFAIR.
LIBERAL LOSERS LOOKING FOR
REASONS THAT ANGRIER THAN
SPILLING A FRESH DRINK ON HER
TODDLER.
NEXT TIME, JULIE, JUST LEAVE TH
RAT BRAT IN THE CAR.
>> OR THE BAR.
>> NO ONE'S LAUGHING AT THAT.
>> MAKE JOKES ABOUT KIDS AND
ALCOHOL, WE'VE CROSSED THE LINE.
THEY CALLED OUT THE IDENTIFIED
MAN WEARING A T-SHIRT WITH AN
AMERICAN FLAG AND A STRIPE AND
THE MIDDLE.
IT'S A SIMPLE ADJUSTER SHOWING
HE SUPPORTS UP.
ALSO DIDN'T LIKE THE RED
BASEBALL CAP, AND SAID MAKE 60
GREAT AGAIN.
WHICH IS THAT MEAN?
THE LAWS OF JUDAISM THE IN A
WORD, HITLER.
CITY ADDRESSED IT SAYING THIS I
A CELEBRATION FOR MY MILES PALM
MILESTONE ASKED IF BIRTHDAY THI
TURNED INTO AN OBSERVANT
POLITICAL ASSUMPTION.
NOTHING RUINS A PARTY FASTER
THAN AN ABSURD POLITICAL
STATEMENT LIKE WHEN A I ASKED
NANCY PELOSI TO STRIP AT MY
BACHELOR PARTY.
THE FIRST THING SHE TOOK OFF WA
HER FACE.
MOLLY, WHAT'S GOING ON, WHY OUR
PEOPLE GETTING MAD AT BIRTHDAY
BATCH IS THERE NOT EVEN INVITED
TO.
I WAS THINKING MAYBE PAUL PELOS
IS THE ONE YOU'D WANT TO PARTY
WITH MORE THAN NANCY.
I AM SICK OF THIS, IT DOESN'T
LOOK MOST AMERICANS WOULD SAY I
IS FINE, BUT WE ARE SEEING THIS
THING WHERE IT'S AN ELEMENT ON
THE LEFT.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL EVERY
ASPECT OF HOLLYWOOD, THEY DON'T
REALLY WANT REPUBLICANS OR
ANYONE WHO'S TOLERANT OF
REPUBLICANS TO BE FREE TO ENJOY
THEMSELVES.
>> I COINED THIS PHRASE IT'S
CALLED TARGET EXPANDING TARGET
EXPANDING DEMOLITION WHICH IS
WHERE YOU'D NOW THAT YOU'RE
WEARING RED, THE CAP IS RED, YO
MUST BE FOR TRUMP SO THEY JUST
KEEP EXPANDING THE DEFINITION.
>> IS, SHE MADE A MISTAKE, IT'S
WHEN THE CYCLE LEFT STARTED TO
THE QUOTE WAS DON'T MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS.
WHEN YOU HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS
WHEN YOU HAVE A MAKE 60 GREAT
AGAIN VERY JUSTLY INTO IT A
LITTLE BIT OR IF YOU WANT, YOU
COULD TAKE A PHOTO AND SAY WHER
CALLING AND THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE.
IT WORKS EVERY TIME.
HOLD ON, EVERYBODY, WE ARE
CALLING AND THE FBI.
JAMES COMEY CAN WEIGH IN ON
WHETHER THERE WAS A REPUBLICAN
SITUATION GOING ON.
>> JULIE, GENERALLY YOU SPEND
YOUR BIRTHDAY'S DRINKING ALONE
IN A CAR IN THE PARKING LOT OF
WALMART, DOES THIS POSED A
PROBLEM FOR YOU, WHAT YOU THINK
OF THIS CLASSIC THINK IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE BLACK LIVES SHE
TWEETED IN SUPPORT OF IT SO IT'
INTERESTING HOW THEY HAVE A
DOUBLE STANDARD, THEY ACTUALLY
MAKE AN EFFORT TO LOOK BACK INT
HER HISTORY BECAUSE SHE FULLY
SUPPORTED BLACK LIVES MATTER,
BUT GOD FORBID YOU HAVE A BLUE
STRIPE IN YOUR SHORT.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
PARALLEL COMES THROUGH.
>> JIM, HAVE YOU EVER ATTENDED
AN ELITE PARTY?
GET WHAT'S BOGGLING TO ME IS
FIRST OF ALL, THE LAST THING I'
LOOKING FOR IS A GUY IN THE
BACKGROUND WITH A BLUE STRIPED
SHIRT.
THERE IS A LOT TO LOOK AT RIGHT
THERE.
AND JUST AS A SOCIETY, WHEN WE
ARE AT THE POINT THAT THERE'S N
OTHER WAY TO HIDE IT, WE
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A PRIVATE
PARTY AND ONE OF THE PEOPLE WAS
WEARING A RED HAT.
DON'T YOU KNOW WE ARE DEFUNDING
THE POLICE?
WE ARE HERE FOR YOUR SAFETY.
WHOEVER COMMENTED OUR PIGS.
GET BACK IN YOUR STA